The second season of DC Universe's Titans
has given hardcore comics fans plenty of hidden
things to find.
There are meaningful passcodes, direct swipes
from comic book covers, and mentions of unseen
beloved characters.
We're breaking down all this and more in our
round-up of Easter eggs you might have missed
in Titans Season 2.
The gun Joe Chill used to murder Bruce Wayne's
parents makes something of an appearance in
the Titans Season 2 premiere.
Trigon subjects the Titans to the same kinds
of visions he used on Dick Grayson in the
Season 1 finale.
In the case of Jason Todd, he inserts the
new Robin into the end of Dick's vision, just
after Dick has killed Batman.
Dick tells Jason that the younger hero is
an animal who "needs to be put down."
Their fight ends with the infamous pistol
sliding from its broken case to the floor
near Jason.
When Jason grabs the gun, Dick suggests Bruce
would never keep the gun loaded.
"No.
But I do."
Does the Titans version of the caped crusader
really keep Joe Chill's gun in the Batcave,
like the Batman of Justice League?
Does Jason actually keep Chill's gun loaded
while he's living with Bruce?
Or is all this just part of the illusion?
Considering we know that in the comics Jason
Todd eventually goes down some dark roads
— including becoming the lethal vigilante
the Red Hood — it's possible that what he
says isn't just part of Trigon's nightmare.
If not, it would not only be a betrayal of
Bruce Wayne's trust, but would point to a
dark turn for the character in the show equal
to what happens in the comics.
Just before Rachel defeats Trigon in the Titans
Season 2 premiere, the possessed Titans wait
nearby, with the dark splotching around their
eyes signaling their new loyalties.
One shot in particular mirrors the cover of
a comic that marked one of the more memorable
battles between the Titans and Trigon.
The cover to 1985's New Teen Titans #4 shows
the heroes standing in a row with their altered
eyes letting us know they're under Trigon's
control.
The players aren't all the same — the cover
to the comic shows Beast Boy, Kid Flash, and
Cyborg.
Also, their eyes are colored red rather than
the skin around their eyes taking on that
inky black look.
Regardless, the meaning behind the respective
eye effects are clear, as is the inspiration
the show takes from the comic.
In New Teen Titans #4, the heroes are forced
to individually wrestle with Trigon's power
just as they are in the Season 2 premiere,
but in a much more literal sense.
Rather than being exposed to nightmare visions
that usually lead the heroes to making horrible
— and often lethal — choices, the heroes
of New Teen Titans #4 fight gray-skinned,
red-eye shadow versions of themselves in the
real world.
One of the more interesting moments in the
brief scenes involving Slade Wilson — aka
Deathstroke — in Season 2 so far is when
he enters a passcode to open his private arsenal.
The conversation between Slade and Wintergreen
suggests it's been a while since Slade has
been home, and the scene in the country store
suggests it's the re-emergence of the Titans
that has brought him back.
When Slade and Wintergreen approach the arsenal,
for a moment it seems Slade may have forgotten
the passcode.
Wintergreen offers to enter it himself, but
Slade insists.
"It's my house."
The code he enters — "5639" — works, and
once you see the code you may wonder if it
was his memory that was bothering him, or
the code himself.
The passcode isn't just a random grouping
of numbers.
If you look closely at the letters corresponding
to the numbers on the keypad, it seems clear
they're based on a name: "Joey."
Joey is a meaningful name in the Deathstroke
mythos, as it's the first name of the superhero
Jericho, Slade Wilson's youngest son.
Actor and activist Chella Man is set to play
him in upcoming episodes of Titans.
The beginning of Season 2 not only sees the
Titans get a home, but gives us the appearance
of one of DC Comics' heroic monuments: Titans
Tower.
In most media before now, Titans Tower has
usually been represented as it was originally
in the comics, as a giant T-shaped building.
It's also usually separated from the mainland
on its own island.
We don't get quite the same tower in Titans,
but the show does pay tribute to the comic
book version.
Though the Tower clearly is made to look more
like a regular office building than the T-shaped
headquarters of the comics, when the camera
pulls back from the Tower at the end of the
season 2 premiere, the Titans' living space
is highlighted while a shadow falls on the
bottom half of the building, making it look
like a T.
Probably the most blatant Easter egg we've
seen in Titans season 2 by the second episode
is a phone call Donna Troy gets after she
and Kori hand off the villain Shimmer to the
police.
As her phone rings, she looks at the screen
and we see the name "Roy Harper" pop up.
Roy Harper has had a number of different superhero
code names over the years, the most recent
being Arsenal.
He was once known as Speedy, Green Arrow's
sidekick.
Colton Haynes occasionally plays the character
on CW's Arrow, and in the comics he was one
of the many superheroes to die in the mini-series
Heroes in Crisis.
Could this be a precursor to Arsenal joining
the Titans?
There's no news about such an addition, but
anything's possible.
It could be that Donna and Roy are dating
and that's the reason for the phone call.
Or perhaps Roy was a member of the previous
incarnation of the Titans, and — like everyone
else in the season 2's second episode — he
has news about the re-emergence of Doctor
Light.
The third episode of Titans' second season,
"Ghosts," has a little bit of fun with DC
Comics' longtime competition.
Hank, Dawn, and Donna finally show up to Titans
Tower to help hunt down Doctor Light, but
they aren't too happy when Dick tells them
Deathstroke's daughter is chilling out in
a bedroom nearby.
Shortly after the exchange, Dick visits Rose
in her bedroom and brings her a black eyepatch
to replace the white bandage she's been wearing
since she was introduced in the previous episode.
Later that night, Rose has an uncharacteristically
friendly conversation with Rachel in the Titans'
kitchen.
Rachel tells Rose her name is pretty.
"Maybe too pretty now.
'Patch' has a nice ring to it."
Likely, the show's creative team is having
a little fun at the expense of one of the
more, well, transparent alter egos in the
history of comics.
Sure, Superman is silly for thinking he could
hide his secret identity with nothing but
a pair of glasses, but he's got nothing on
Marvel's Wolverine, who took on the least
convincing alter ego ever in the beginning
of his first ongoing solo series.
While in Southeast Asia, Wolverine wore a
black eyepatch and navigated the criminal
underworld by calling himself "Patch," apparently
thinking no one would notice his trademark
hair.
Nice try, Patch!
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
DC characters are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.